across ukraine the war rages on
hear the sound of battle in the southern
coastal city of mikhail
while above another city in the east
ukraine says it shot a russian jet out
of the sky
[Music]
sky news has verified the location of
the footage in kharkiv though not who's
hitting what
ukraine's president urged the world to
put even more pressure on russia to end
its war
if the invasion continues and russia
doesn't give up its plans in regards to
ukraine then a new set of sanctions
needs to be introduced
on a visit to lithuania the top u.s
diplomat insisted unprecedented
punishments by western allies against
moscow are working we see
the ruble going through the floor
we see russia's credit rating coming
basically to zero to junk status as we
would call it we see its stock market
shut down we see an exodus of virtually
every leading company
uh from russia all of those things are
happening they're happening in real time
but president vladimir putin remains on
the offensive
these images from his defense ministry
show the moment an airstrike is launched
the u.s says some 600 russian missiles
have been fired against ukraine in the
past 12 days
seeking safety from the threat people
flee the port city of odessa
in other areas though it's no longer
safe to escape and attempts to open
humanitarian corridors keep failing
this is mariopol also on the coast and
the scene of some of the worst
bombardments
it has been established that the
nationalists threatening violence are
simply not releasing civilians and
foreign citizens from the aforementioned
locations
but ukraine's accused russia of
cynically only allowing safe passage to
its territory or to its close ally
belarus
this is an unacceptable option of
creating humanitarian corridors
our people from ivankov daimar fishgarad
and kiev won't go to belarus to fly
later to russia
the two sides met again for a third
round of talks
but no sign of any breakthrough as the
bombs keep
falling
and ukraine's military keeps resisting
debra haynes sky news lev western
ukraine